and they have no idea what they're doing
I don't care what he can do there's too
many so yeah we actually see his ship
here you can see oh that's his crash
ship in the background there so we're
already starting to see his like Escape
Plan
you're all dead to me right I love this
villain
um he's gonna stop on everybody yep and
and now we're certain we gotta ask like
what is this war that's going on like
who's fighting seriously it looks messy
it's messy bless this mess oh and hey we
want to thank nordvpn for sponsoring our
show today more on them in a bit but
welcome back to new rock stars
quantumania drops the Ant-Man family
into a Quantum realm that's overtaken by
War a war not started by Scott Lang and
his family but one that Kang might use
him to finish what was this war what is
it being fought over who are the war in
factions who's gonna win quantumania
sometimes I have to listen to you say
first and then I'll know how to say it
sometimes I write it one way and I
forget how I intended to say it so it's
just kind of a Quantum mayonnaise
this is inside Marvel it's it's a Marvel
new Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction
show I'm Eric boss I'm back for my
honeymoon I'm so happy to be back on the
show with Jessica Clements and Mt Hello
friends dude how's the honeymoon man oh
it was wild
um we I found another multiversal Eric
who can just enjoy himself and relax by
a pool didn't know he existed but he's
out there somewhere
I had a great time I thought you were
just on a vacation again
yeah I I did a thing where we were gonna
go over the holidays but instead I
worked through the holidays and it's
like we didn't want to go to Costa Rica
when there's gonna be a bunch of kids
there but you know what it doesn't
matter because the first two weeks of
January there's apparently a lot of
parents who are like who cares if our
kid missed school
anyway so a lot of kids the kids were
all nice nice kids only a bit of
splashing buttons can't complain too
much it's now quantumania season
everybody we're getting almost like
daily drops of like little promos it's
almost get a little borderline spoilery
but Kevin feige himself is even like all
right he just wants his ship he wants a
ship all right who cares we're not who
cares about spoiler anymore but that's I
think honestly they want to entice
people to see this they might be a
little worried that people aren't going
to see this movie we're all going to
show up in full force don't worry oh
yeah cook it already did you guys get
your tickets I did I got mine for 7 p.m
at the Dolby I had to get it in Dolby or
IMAX so that's why I'm seeing it at 7
p.m I would have saw it at like door and
skipped out on work but yeah I'm ready
I'm ready to go man well we're going to
today be talking about the latest news
about Quantum maintenance specifically
that the quantum realm is apparently a
war and we're going to be asking who's
fighting whom in that war what side is
Scott gonna be on in it I assume it's
gonna switch sides at some point uh But
be sure to head over to new
rockstarsmerch.com and grab yourselves
all kinds of uh merch from shirts and
hoodies stickers pins hats uh we're
gonna have some new shirts inspired by
uh Ant-Man the West quantumania so uh
stay tuned for that yes the designs are
dope yeah they look really cool so uh
the question today what is this Quantum
realm War all about why is the Quantum
realm at War
um and I think everyone saw this but uh
when the quantomania trailer released
last week empty by the way you did such
a good job breaking down that trailer
thank you good like your theories are
amazing but there was this one press
release that came out with some
interesting tidbits about the plot and
I'm quoting the press release here it
says with Scott and Cassie pulled in One
Direction and hope Janet and Hank pulled
in another they are lost in a world at
war with no idea how or if they'll ever
find their way home again a world at war
implies that they're all they kind of
stumble into a war zone and we've seen
flashes of this war in the trailers
Kang's Army and its Fleet mobilizing
Kang looking out over the quantum realm
watching his Fighters getting shot down
and we also learned a bit more about the
cast giving us a sense of who the
different Power factions are in the
quantum realm potentially who is at War
here uh we got Lord krylar that's gonna
be Bill Murray's character He's listed
as the governor of Axia a-x-i-a which is
a bizarre and cushy Community within the
quantum realm so it sounds like I don't
know the Eagleton of quantum realm or
like
Bel Air Quantum realm the Presidio hype
Quantum realm the I don't know what is
it in Manhattan
um I don't know Upper Manhattan I don't
know everything's Rich to me yeah
I want to go to the Pawnee of the
quantum realm please send me there yeah
foreign
yeah but um so uh you know with Bill
Murray's character it says call him
cowardly or self-centered Chrysler
aren't unapologetically enjoys the High
Life his status grants him expensive
meals exotic cocktails top-notch
Transportation aboard his huge pleasure
yet it seems he and Janet are old
acquaintances but the details are vague
and she'd like to keep it that way then
we got Katie O'Brien's character who's
playing gen Torah G
j-e-n-t-o-r-r-a described as a strong
respected leader of the Freedom Fighters
just called the Freedom Fighters they
didn't come up with a better name just
Freedom Fighters there's no time
um like we got fireflies in The Last of
Us he could have picked us guys
equally not that great of a name
um a little bit better than Freedom
Fighters the flag splashes were the uh
you guys it's early yeah well the
Hawkeye had the track suits we could
have gotten the tracksuits were kind of
freedom fighters in their own right I
think and that name was superb that name
was great yeah you can't fault that
um but this a group of Freedom Fighters
is described as a group of displaced
inhabitants in the quantum realm whose
lives were turned upside down by Kang
gentura doesn't have time for Scott
Cassie and their problems and worse
their presence alone puts chintara's
crew in grave danger we actually got a
photo tutorial that just came out and we
learned that William Jackson Harper are
man from uh the good place and from
midsomar he's so good he's playing a
character named quas or quays who's all
we know about him is that he's a
telepath and we got a photo of him from
Empire as well uh with gentura at the
right of him um so we got a couple
warring factions here different Power
Players in this conflict we got Lord
krylard Bill Murray who seems like the
sitting government or whatever some kind
of like oligarch figurehead of at least
the rich Community
um we got Kang who seems to be an
invading threat uh against whatever the
status quo is then we got the freedom
fighters who were basically stirred up
by Kang and whatever he's doing
performing a kind of Grassroots gorilla
Manisha militia and then we got the
Ant-Man family coming in throwing a
wrench into all of this so we gotta ask
ourselves what is the Quantum realm War
being fought over the description for
gentura says that the lives of her and
the Freedom Fighters were turned upside
down by Kang it's me that sounds like
you know in any kind of War conflict
Farmers or settlers uh whose land might
have been taken over by mining or
imminent domain manufacturing
manufacturing industrialization like
imagine Saruman displacing the ants and
Lord of the Rings you know just like uh
so all the ants uh it's like basically
Ant-Man and the in The Hobbit
quantumintia I I'm forcing this here
um well one thing I've been cooking up
for this uh for a deep dive that I'm
doing on the new channel is uh this idea
that Kang might be after Quantum ore
because we know Sylvie was digging for
Quantum ore uh and that that could be
basically the fuel that Kang and kangs
in the future use to power all their
technology and maybe we're seeing it at
its root of quantum particles that could
be the same root raw material for pin
particles so he's trying to like dig all
this up in the quantum realm for some
kind of raw energy state or something
like that
um that's just me theorizing but I'm
wondering if like you got Lord krylar he
was supposed to watch over can keep him
trapped in the quantum realm that was
his job he's like kind of the warden but
over the years Kang won krylar's trust
and offered his technological Services
as a Master of Arms or a master of
Technology but all this time secretly
planning to overthrow krylar and escape
the Quan realm and he created uh but
this these efforts created a new enemy
of freedom fighters who have stopped
Kang from gathering enough of a steel
resource so King's like damn it what do
I do but then Scott Lang arrives with
his refined pin particles giving Kang a
shortcut to get out of here uh because I
think Kang needs to use pin particles to
shrink whatever weapon or resource so it
can be stolen and put in a fuel chamber
source for his ship I went to a lot of
theory three places what do you guys
think is going on with this one oh my
God it
it I
talked about this on the break room
briefly I think or maybe it was worked
there out I
that I think Lord kreiler has something
that's needed and maybe it's that maybe
it's a situation but I think he still
has something that's needed and is
protected and Kang has kind of worked
closely with him and so did Janet at one
point but no one else can really get
behind those bars if that makes sense I
just it's like I understand that he's
like a sitting government but the idea
of him having the pleasure yacht and
just being like a rich person with a lot
of money that's just like I'm having fun
I'm living a very lavish life I'm like
okay so you have something that's
important something worth taking over so
there's something you're hiding there
that I think Kang needs a part of as
well not just the pen particles or what
Ant-Man has so I want to believe that
there's something behind those bars that
he has to get into that is really hard
to break into but I could be also wrong
no I I do think that there is something
that with mining that is going to be big
in this movie and like it's going to be
something to do with like mining this
like Quantum energy that um is like a
really really big resource and I feel
like this entire movie is sort of like a
um what what do you call it like a um a
warning for the future of the MCU like
this is what Kang is going to do to the
macroverse when he gets out and um like
oh you see all these warring factions
like this is like sort of like what what
is going to happen to the MCU and like
with with krylar
um I think with him we're going to see
him being mirrored
um with like this Quantum Energy race
that is teasing at Ant-Man 2. um I think
that he might be like on a microverse
level someone that benefited from mining
this mining this Quantum energy source
and um you know but like
he's like sort of like
it's sort of messed up because like he's
helping Kang so like he's fueling King's
um Enterprise by giving him his energy
source so like I don't know I feel like
what we're seeing in the quantum realm
this whole War
um between like um I feel like Kenny is
just taking over these areas and Lee
wants to take over the entire Quantum
realm before he goes off and he goes
does his own thing do you think he's
higher than everybody else in the
quantum realm then everybody works
underneath gang it just seems like when
you have a team of only five people and
everything we've seen the trailer is you
alone I'm like who is really with you
see I think the way I see it is similar
to like the history the the French
Revolution or really like the years
after the French Revolution so you have
like the sitting government the monarchy
the Marie Antoinette so let them eat
cake that that's uh
cake
in English but um the the uh that's Lord
krylar he's the oligarch you know he's a
disconnect from his people then you have
overweight in the shadows he got
Napoleon Napoleon came in the years
after the French Revolution kind of
reestablished France as an Empire and a
military dictatorship but I think Kang
is the Napoleon of the situation he's
kind of he's building his his warring
faction his War Machine and then you
have basically the the poor displaced
revolutionaries on the ground level who
just make any kind of governance
impossible because they're like none of
you are listening to us right now you're
taking our land you're burning our Farms
screw you so it kind of makes it the gov
though the quantrum impossible to govern
I don't think Kang is in power yet but I
think he has he's like quietly Palpatine
in his clothes yeah and also getting
them all to fight each other it's like
they're doing the work I don't have to
do until the very end when I need to get
out so as long as they're all dealing
with themselves I'll show up eventually
I mean uh history nerds know that there
was definitely a period between the the
1989 French Revolution and when Napoleon
took over but we're really talking about
a period of like I think 12 years or so
but there was like a temporary
government in between where it was like
radical like uh revolutionaries who were
beheading people in the streets in the
name of like uh democracy and things
like that things got really crazy in
France for like a decade there at the
end of the 18th century it's awesome
read up on it obviously you said that
you said 1989.
holy [ __ ]
the 80s were wild
but you know in 1989 pretty wild too you
had um a Little Mermaid came out
um The Wall came down the headings
yeah
what's interesting what do you think
about wars throughout history they're
usually fought over the same kinds of
things you got Wars over natural
resources including land uh you got Wars
over religion that were fought you got
Wars over like uh ethnic and racism and
that kind of stuff like that different
like uh Strife there so like of these
three I kind of feel like any of them
could be the option I don't get a sense
of a lot of religion in the quantum
realm but I do get a sense of like
natural resources and land I feel like
that's the other thing well the natural
resource echo which is interesting
because it's like we talked about this
on the break room yesterday whether or
not Kang is gonna try to destroy the
quantum realm once he's out and we were
like yeah what's gonna because these are
all people they're not only just like
people that were born within the quantum
realm they're humans that are now
trapped in the quantum realm so it's
like what is it gonna take to do any of
the situation what does it mean towards
the end when you guys are realizing like
oh we were fighting over these minuscule
things and this man's trying to destroy
all that we know and love yeah that's a
good point like I would imagine Kang
would hate the quantum realm he's like
someone who was they finally found a
prison that could trap him he never
wants to get stuck down there again it's
like when a mouse escapes a mouse trap
he always destroys it is that true
that's not true
I was like in what world does the mouse
have the power to destroy the Trap
hey here's the road Theory do we think
the rat that freed Scott from the
quantum realm was being uh puppeted by
Kang oh fun I like that theory more than
oh my God uh whatever that means in a
way I suppose what happens
from the traps I hate that I just pulled
the um what's this miles from uh Glass
Onion you just say something with enough
confidence
thank God I did otherwise I'd have been
like oh yeah I read that once you
repeated to someone else and they're
like what are you doing what are you
talking about I don't think he can
destroy this is it going back but I I
don't think he's gonna completely
destroy the quantum realm and I think
that's where Ant-Man comes into playing
realizes what he did where he really did
when he's like I will take whatever it
takes to get my family together and then
also let not make this man get out he's
gonna try to protect the remaining lives
in the quantum realm and Kang is going
to get out essentially uh while that is
happening in the play yeah but I yeah I
don't think the quantum can be destroyed
it's a crucial part of reality
that I that's what we said about the
rainforest of teeth
no more no more of these metaphors
bolsonaro proved us wrong there but no I
I I think that like it's too crucial
part of reality
um it's like the root of like all of MCU
existence so like I feel like you can't
fully destroy it you can kill a lot of
people like to destroy the whole realm
it is needed the quantum realm is very
important but I think the situation of
them changing it from the microverse to
like the quantum realm from the comics
they're like we need to wreck on a lot
of situations we need to Recon the fact
that there is more Realms within the
microverse we need to wreck on a lot of
stuff and we they made it so well they
made it so we only know what we've
learned from Ant-Man that only What Hank
Pym and Lawrence Fishburne has told us
so I'm like what happens when we turn it
into the nowhere head and we just Hollow
it out and it's just a empty vessel that
no one can enter anymore and there's
nothing there this is this is getting
deep and so I for one episode of the
break room I had to study uh physics to
understand
I'm sorry I want you to know that I
didn't even pass Algebra 2 in high
school so this
made no sense for me to be studying I
don't understand how boxes work physics
I mean like you have to be a nuclear
physicist to be on the break room right
here so like that's what I heard get it
get yourself together two is hard I
could get through geometry Algebra 2
throws a wrench at you in quarter three
where it's like okay now we're gonna do
vectors and sohcahtoa and I'm like screw
you with sohcahtoa I don't want to do
this yeah sign over cosine cosine over
10 to that that kind of stuff
what's
no I'm not gonna say anything but that
sounds like a historical figure from uh
coming out of my mouth it sounds
defensive it sounds like uh it's
definitely a Colonial Williamsburg tour
guide who's like I'm allowed to say this
because I'm appreciating the history of
it so it's like somebody that was at the
first Thanksgiving uh that's all I'll
say there
Jacksonville Florida they taught a
sohcahtoa which is like it's an acronym
study for like sign over you know Sign
Co side and tangent they all relate to
each other in different ways in a
different yeah oh whatever I regret
everything
but it was hard that part was hard for
me calculus was easier for me than that
was because you know you don't have to
memorize geometry but you have to
memorize sohcahtoa
yeah yeah it's it's math down with math
um up with not math that's what I say
put that on shirt
uh wow uh we have an uh more about
Quantum media we want to get into but
first we want to thank our sponsors of
this episode uh thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring this episode we watch a lot
of movies and series here at new
rockstars one thing that makes the
process of streaming all that content
better is nordvpn with nordvpn you can
change your virtual location with just
one click which which makes it easier to
find streaming platforms at a lower
price uh we can even access platforms
that aren't available in the United
States with just one click you can
choose from over
5400 servers in 60 countries that way we
never miss out on our favorite content
whether we're at home or traveling and
if you're worried that nordvpn might
cause buffering when you're watching
content fear not nordvpn provides
amazing speed thanks to Nord links so
you can stream securely without
bandwidth throttling nordvps benefits
and features go way Beyond improving
your streaming experience you can also
access games and discounts only
available in other regions and block
malware written websites while you
explore securely we encourage you to try
nordvpn for yourself so grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com Marvel to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus four
additional months for free it's
completely risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee that's
n-o-r-d-vpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months for free we
also want to thank Turbo Tax for
sponsoring this episode go to TurboTax
and don't do your taxes meet with an
expert who will do them for you Turbo
Tax experts can relieve you from the
stress of taxes and file for you so you
can do not taxes show your eyes things
that are not taxes unpack a moving box
of not taxes taste not taxes sing not
tax is a lullaby hope not taxes sleeps
through the night grab a saddle and ride
and not taxes into the sunset with Turbo
Tax an expert will do your taxes from
start to finish ensuring your taxes are
done right guaranteed so you can relax
feels good to be done with your taxes
doesn't it come to Turbo Tax and don't
do your taxes visit turbotax.com to
learn more Intuit TurboTax full service
products only video meeting while expert
does your taxes required see guaranteed
details at turbotax.com guarantees all
right getting back to quantumania here
uh I have a weird take I want to throw
at the two of you the character of
Cassie Lang they did something really
weird they recast Emma firm and as
Catherine Newton and you know what
Justice for Emma Furman Emma Furman did
a great job in that scene and end game
and they just brought in Katherine
Newton I don't know why I would have
been okay with them if you're a NSR as
our stature but in this trailer they
bring back Abby Ryder Fortson which
almost feels like a diss to him to
Catherine Newton it's like let this
young actor move on why can't Scott just
get over the fact that his daughter's
older he's not saying I missed the five
years I miss my little baby girl when I
could pick her up but she didn't go to
jail it's weird it's a little weird so
do we think is this intentional is
Cassie Lang going to be the first MCU
character who exists as multicasted
different actor variants and all three
of these young women will be playing
Cassie Lang and the Multiverse going
forward Mt didn't you say did you say
this empty did you put this oh I I did I
do think that we are going to see uh
little Cassie again in this movie I
think that seeing her in the trailer
usually means that like we also got the
actor to come back
um like what for example we're seeing
Tom Holland
um in uh in an end game it's like I see
your picture like oh yeah if you're
seeing a picture of Tom Holland then
he's probably in this movie
um he's gonna come back so like I think
that we're gonna see a a variant or or
we're gonna see Scott go back in time to
actually get to say goodbye to um to
little Cassie so we might see Abby
writer Fortson again Emma Furman I do
not think I like this idea of Emma
Furman coming back as a very be really
fun I would love to see that
um play into like the Multiverse
narrative
um but like I don't I don't know if
she's back in this movie it would be
cool but like it would be kind of weird
people be kind of confused like wait you
were an end game but now we have her so
like why are you here
are there are uh end game is like the
second biggest movie of all time there's
gonna be more people who think of Scott
Lang's daughter as Emma Furman than
people look at Catherine this is true
okay so I said last time we talked about
Cassie Lang which I've said like three
times you guys and I know you guys kind
of hate it but I'm gonna say one more
time I think Cassie's gonna die and I
think she's gonna die and she's gonna be
resurrected I don't think she's gonna
die for good I think that's just the
justification of like hey if you want
your daughter back I can give you more
time I can bring her back uh I just need
you to do one little thing for me and
I'll bring her back I think that's
ultimately what he's really going for
and that's why she can get out of the
quantum room come back in in costume but
someone someone was like What if this
Cassie Lang is just a variant what if he
kills this 616 Cassie Lang and brings in
a Cassie Lang from a different place and
I was like oh
I would love that so the situation is
like that situation very stretch I
understand but could possibly give way
to why we would have multiple Cassie
layings and this would be an easy
justification instead of just being like
we changed the actor like you can you
can do that with um with um Don
cheadle's character because I think it
was so long ago that Iron Man we kind of
were just like uh yeah we'll just switch
it up but now it's like you could just
say it's the Multiverse you can say this
is a different version of her right and
we can just address it as that and I
think that's fine I think that's
completely fine so you're saying we're
gonna get a fourth cast healing played
by Henry yes how did you know
that would be amazing
um
like I would not hold Cheeto verse we
have a spider versus every time he plays
a baron he goes it's me I'm here get
over it
I think it's a great idea I think it's
easily Justified if you just say it's a
Multiverse and it just like we know
we're gonna like okay so Secret Wars
you're gonna start just throwing
everybody in right your hands just start
throwing people from different places oh
yeah so might as well start that now
with being like how easy and seamlessly
it has to be for us to like throw
someone in from a different timeline
um the baby one yeah she's gotta make
her come back Emma Furman I don't think
she'll make her come back but I think
this will be her justification now I
would imagine the the baby Cassie played
by Abby Ryder Fortson is probably a bit
older now right they shot quantumania in
2017. it's now 2023 she's probably like
she's at the I think she's like 56 now
like you are a tween now so she is
definitely not the yeah Daddy
I really miss little Cassie like she did
such a great job those movies I'm like
oh look at Scott and his daughter this
is so adorable you guys are so cute
together like I missed that Dynamic like
uh it's gonna be weird she was too old
to have a Thomas the Tank Engine train
set though
for a little girl to have a Thomas to
take it yeah Thomas the Tank Engine is a
creepy Thomas the Tank Engine is only
for little boys ages three haven't seen
bullet train where he is like 33 years
old with a Thomas the Tank that's right
that's true he loves Thomas
he's so good in that movie can that
movie win all the others
every award because I love him so good
the two of them him and Aaron Taylor
Johnson were my favorite part of that
movie I thought they were so good all
right we will leave it there for this
episode of inside Marvel it's so good to
be back with the two of you um you can
follow Jessica at Lulu underscore
Clements you can follow Mt at masterton
you can follow me at eavos be sure to
subscribe to inside Marvel whatever you
get your podcast if you're so inclined
we'd love if you could pre-subscribe
over to the Deep dive Channel some fun
stuff planned over there
um but I can't wait to uh explore
Quantum media season and phase five with
the two of you on inside Marvel every
week it's
gonna be fun all right we'll see
everyone next week bye-bye everybody bye
foreign
[Music]